[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome back to
8.20, special relativity.
In this section, and
also the next time,
we talk about electromagnetism.
Electromagnetism is not
part of the core of 8.20.
We are not requiring
electromagnetism
as part of the prerequisite.
I will not test or include
electromagnetism in the final.
But nevertheless, it's
interesting to discuss
electromagnetic effects in the
context of special relativity,
as they led to the development
of special relativity
in the first.
After all, the paper
which describes
the theory of special relativity
is about the electrodynamics
of moving bodies.
And so let's have a look at
the natural dynamics of moving
bodies.
And so here, we have a source--
a charge which is moving
with a velocity V.
And moving charges, or currents,
create magnetic fields.
You can use your right-hand
and see particles are
moving in this direction here.
The electric field lines
are curling around you.
Good.
So now I have a second
charge-- a test charge which
is moving with the velocity u.
That test charge will
experience the magnetic force.
The force is equal to
the test charge itself,
qt, times u cross
B, the velocity
cross the magnetic field.
So there's clearly
a magnetic force
acting on this [INAUDIBLE]
charge in this reference frame.
However, if I now move
into a reference frame
where the source
charge is stationary,
a stationary charge is not
creating magnetic field,
so the magnetic field is 0.
Hence the magnetic force
on the test charge is 0.
I can, alternatively, look at
the reference frame in which
the test charge is stationary.
And so also here,
because u is equal to 0,
the magnetic force is 0.
So clearly, we do have to treat
magnetic and electric fields
in sort of a
consistent manner as we
treated time and space,
and energy momentum
in a consistent manner.
But we need a concept of
electromagnetic fields.
And previously in this class, we
looked at electromagnetic field
light before.
The difference here is-- and
that's the context of the next
section--
is that you want to understand
how we create those fields--
how we can create electric
and magnetic fields, and how
that all works together.
Now the first
activity, I want you
to consider a cube of
length L with n electrons.
There's n charges inside,
and everything is at rest.
And what I want
you to figure out
is what is the charge and
current density [INAUDIBLE]
and j0 of this cube?
There's a second step.
As you can imagine, I ask you
to consider the very same thing
from a moving reference frame,
S prime, with some velocity
u which is the velocity of
S prime with respect to S.
What is the charge in
the current density now
in this new reference frame?
I'd like you to figure this out.
So now we look at this cube,
and the total number of charges
is N. The length--
or the volume is l0 cubed.
And so the density is
N divided by l0 cubed.
The current 0.
Nothing is moving.
There's no moving
charges [INAUDIBLE]..
All right, this one is
more straightforward.
But now in our moving reference
frame, the situation changes.
Here, one of the directions--
the direction in which we are
moving--
is Lorentz contracted.
So we have lx equal
to lx 0 or l0, times--
divided by gamma, or times
square root 1 minus u
squared over c squared.
The volume then of the same cube
in the S prime reference frame
is l0 cubed divided by gamma.
The number of
electrons, however,
is unchanged, so the charge
density is the previous charge
density divided by the volume.
And if you compare--
sorry, it's the charge divided
by the new volume which
is the density times gamma.
For the new charge
density, we simply
have to multiply
the current density.
For the current density, we
have to multiply the charge
density times the velocity.
And again, we find ro
0 times 0, times gamma.
Good.
So if you look at
those relations,
they look very much
like the relationship
between the current
and the charge density.
They look very much
like the relations
we had between momentum and
energy, and time and space.
And Lorentz transformation
looks very similar.
So we can, motivated
by this, write
a 4 vector, which is the first
component c times the density.
And as the first, second, and
third component, the current.
And you find that
the invariant here
is very similar to time and
space, energy and momentum
given as the density where
the charges are addressed.
And that's the invariant,
and you can calculate this
from multiplying the 4 vector
[INAUDIBLE] square [INAUDIBLE]..
So concept questions.
Is the electric charge conserved
in the Lorentz transformation,
or did we actually
change the charge?
So we have the charge density
here and the current here,
but did we actually
change the charge
on the Lorentz [INAUDIBLE]?
The answer is, no, we
did not change them,
so the charge is conserved.
The charge is invariant in
the Lorentz transformation.
Is electric current conserved
in Lorentz transformation,
or invariant on the
Lorentz transformation?
Should rather use
invariant [INAUDIBLE]..
And the answer is, no, it's not.
So we have seen from
the very first example
that you start with
the current which is 0,
and then in the S prime
frame, the current
is of a certain value.
So certainly, the
current was seen
from two different
observers is changed.